sí buenas tardes angela más que afectar
el país económicamente porque las
sanciones eeuu son las que si van en
contra de instituciones venezolanas
afecta a los funcionarios del gobierno
de nicolás maduro esta vez como dijiste
a las 19 personas que fueron sancionadas
de hace pocos días está la
vicepresidenta del país decir rodríguez
y también diosdado cabello que es el
segundo al mando ellos no pueden entrar
al bloque europeo y también tienen
congelados cualquiera de diez bienes y
los tienen allí en la unión europea'
esta no es la primera vez que el
gobierno arremete contra la embajadora
de la unión europea en venezuela esto lo
hizo también el 29 de junio del año
pasado pero al final una conversación
entre nicolás maduro y borre el echó
para atrás la decisión hace pocos
minutos manejamos tope a pidió al govern
a nicolás maduro que se retracte sobre
lo que ha hecho en día de hoy
gracias herminio